We're surrounded just be cool, just be cool. Oh, there's Niko. I see him
I've been working with Sam and Niko since 2009 today
I'm a go to the lifeline set my boys Sam and Niko are shooting the biggest project of their careers
I'm like a proud Papa watching them and seeing them in action and hopefully you guys learn something along the way come on
Yeah, well, I don't have a car
Last week, picked up this light and it wasn't working. let me show you
Wonder why these lights don't work I wonder why. These lights are made like bricks. They could take an atom bomb. I'll plug the light in
Give it power
Turn it on
Doesn't turn on. but if you look carefully right here the fan is actually spinning
So the control panel works, the light actually works
So that's a problem
I don't know. They're somewhere in here. We don't know where. I say let's go this way
I think it's still up further.
That's what the studio is. It's just on the first floor, dude you were right Nick we should have wen't down.
i... no, no... dude why. Of course!
I was just checking the subreddit. I haven't check it in several days.
I'm a mod so I can change this I think. this is not acceptable. I want to change that.
Didn't notice it. No. I hadn't noticed it until you pointed it out
Now it's all I can see. That's the one like the people ate on fear factor
um
What are you doing? I'm editing the scene
about the subreddit
Actually the photo was removed, since then.
aw, look.
It's okay Wren, you can come out.
So I'm just looking for a clip exact clip. I'm context is one already yes. I'm warm wow
What is this freaking bite me all need to shut up?
That Iraqi let's get lunch spider, [Kamat] [aspire] [bail]
Where we can?
Work it on my mind. Yeah, wherein said where's it says upstairs upstairs [which] love the book okay? Thank you
Thank you closer. We'll find it something who is just a stand down well? How do we get to the second floor?
six stairs oh yeah
Get you
The story, thank you
You go to sex of me just broke for lunch down the street at Grand Central market. Let's go. Oh
Here we are now we have to find Nico and Sam
It's like being at a cia location is that that guy where comes that you see people with the little radios probably it's like FBI
Holy house where Nico is oh
There's makeup. I think you can't just go up to him dude. We're surrounded if we just go up to him
We're getting it attack. They're serious people we have trained into
once Watford engine
Hey whats up guys? Hey welcome to the lunch. Yeah
This is a really nice light that we like to use
It doesn't work jared has an idea of what could be wrong with it. Let's ask it
Okay in production lights have color their color temperature Tungsten
which is kind of [Orangie] and day life which is blue you like accordingly so that if y balance is opposed that's
Production lighting in a very very basic bottom line these are tungsten leds if one sweetie. Oh
We also have daylight
Leds [one] [day] when he needs 120 t power source
120 deep if we instead hook this up to you the proper guy that might fix this
Okay
And again my tix calls from the telemarketer come going striking
Apparently you can you know hit technology and make it boot well there we go. There you go
sure
so lesson learned
When working with the tungsten or the daylight?
Aperture 120 lights you want to make sure you don't mix up the controller panel, or else it won't actually work; good to know!
Well, we finally found the set of Lifeline and we're here to say
we feel
Hi guys
So this is the set of Lifeline's headquarters, we call it the bull pen just look at the rare Sam
No, no. It's not rare you guys are rare. I'm always here
This is our main headquarters set, I don't know how much we should actually should of this though
This is the kind of stuff that like pick up and then I'll be fitted try just blur everything except my face look how cool
We're shooting all our headquarters beans in this sweet sweet sweet studio here taking the whole space apart throwing a huge desk tons of light
Installation stuff it full of background extras and stuff and make it look like a buckling office. It's crazy. We've been shooting for over five weeks
Yeah. we're back! We're back in. Hear that? We're back in. Hey guys we're back
We're back in. While, Sam and Niko go off and do their thing
we're going to take this opportunity to show you guys a little bit about the differences between
A very large set the way things work on those sets
Versus how the way things work when we're just shooting Youtube videos. I was fortunate enough to fly to New York City to meet the Rock
He smells great. Did you just call him , did you call him Dwayne?
I called him dwayne. it was a magical part of my life
I'm sad to see it forever wait. So you mean that he made it to the top with with hard work and dedication
Yes, hard work and dedication. He outperformed.